in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, from May 9th, on which we commemorate the memory of
the holy and great martyr, Christopher, with Kalinika, Aquilina, and the two hundred
soldiers who came to believe in Christ through him.
In the fourth year of the reign of Decius, in 251, soldiers arrived in an eastern town
and put all Christians they found there to torture.
A gigantic and very ugly young mercenary called Repribus from a barbaric tribe was seized
with compassion at the site.
Unable, however, to communicate with the Christians in their language, he fell to his
knees and transformed by the innate upsurge of nature, made a prayer to God.
An angel then appeared to him and, touching his lips, gave him the power of understanding
the language of the Romans.
Filled with boldness by this heavenly vision, Repribus returned to the town and covered the
persecutors with reproach, confessing his faith in Christ.
A certain bocus threw himself on him to punch him in the face.
The giant led him and replied gently, it is through obedience to Christ's commandments
that I endure these blows.
If I were to give free reign to my anger, the whole of your corrupt empire would be unable
to resist me.
The emperor, having been advised of the situation, sent a squad of two hundred soldiers to arrest
the rebellious man.
After a thorough search, they found him at the moment when, praying in front of a church
and having planted his staff in the earth, the stick had immediately burst into leaf.
The saint asked them to give him a little more time to receive holy baptism.
And in order to prove the favor he had received from God, he multiplied the soldier's provisions.
They coming at once to faith in Christ.
They then went together to Antioch, where they were baptized by Saint Babelus, Repribus receiving
the name Christopher, Christ Barer.
When the saint was summoned before the emperor, the latter terrified by his terrible and repulsive
appearance fell over backwards.
Having regained control over himself, he tried to make him renounce his faith.
Not daring to provoke the giant with threats, he had two prostitutes, Kalinika and Aquilina
sent to him with orders to employ all their charms to draw Christopher into fornication and
thence to idol worship.
But the opposite happened.
Christopher converted the two women, showing them that nothing on earth could be compared
with eternal life.
They confessed their sins and the saint interceded for them before God.
The next day, they came before the emperor and confessed their faith.
Cassius in fury had them hanged by their hair, with heavy stones tied to their feet.
Aquilina expired under the torture on the 1st of April.
On the following day, Kalinika made as though she submitted and asked to be taken to the
idol temple.
After having been shown the statue of Zeus, she tied her girdle to it and exerting all her
strength pulled it down.
She then did the same with the statues of Hercules and Apollo.
Seized immediately by the pagans, she was spitted from her feet to her shoulders and gave
her soul into God's hands, confiding herself to St. Christopher's prayers.
Five days later, turning his wrath on the soldiers who had been converted by St. Christopher,
the tyrant had them beheaded and ordered that their bodies be burned outside the town.
They remained, however, intact and the Christians gave them honorable burial.
Decius then had the saint shut in a bronze vessel pierced with four holes and placed it
on a brazier, but Christopher did not feel the burning.
And at the sight of this, more than a thousand pagans who were there cried out, great is the
God of the Christians.
Then they fell at the martyr's feet, saying, you are rightly called Christopher because you
truly carry Christ in your heart and thus count for nothing the torments of the tyrants.
The saint from within the furnace taught them the principles of the Christian faith and revealed
to them that he was contemplating in a vision a great and majestic personage, more
resplendent than the sun, with a crown on his head and surrounded by myriads of soldiers
with faces aflamed, who crushed the black hordes of demons hurling themselves against them.
Learning thus of Christ's victory over all the evil ones undertakings, the newly converted
Christians delivered the saint, but the next day the emperor, fearing a riot, took the
opportunity on a pagan festival to execute all who had declared themselves to be Christians
and disciples of Saint Christopher.
He then ordered that Saint Christopher be chained to a heavy mill wheel and cast into a pit
whence he was delivered by an angel.
They then put a red hot bronze preras on him, but the valorous martyr remained impassable
under the pain.
Finally, having exhausted the resources of his perverse imagination, the tyrant had him beheaded
on the 9th of May.
Shortly afterwards the bishop of Atalia brought the martyr's body and solemnly translated
to the city, where Saint Christopher became its protector against intemperance and calamity.
His veneration spread very widely during the middle ages, both in the east and in the west.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.